[Music]
guys
what's here
robber
it's here no way it's here dude
hold on
and
boom
we did it
yeah baby it is the world
tess
championship
that's what i'm talking about this one
has the copyright c where's that danny
look you get it no look at it look at it
you'll see you'll see
here there's a few others
it's the design
that one nice here i want that one you
see it bob you get it now yeah no i have
no idea what
no his face there's missing c's all
right
robert you want to
explain
you you know my name the game you play
it's called chess right and there's no
word championship it's championship
so there's a c you know yeah yeah
no
i mean i think it's i think it's
hilarious and don't you think people
would would buy this
no i don't think anyone's gonna buy that
hey that's the stupidest person in my
life
well holy sh
you think it's too late to send it back
i ordered a lot
[Music]
you